[NC]: Halloweentown high
Yeah, okay... They made so many of these movies,
I'm surprised there's not a "Halloweentown Surfs Up" or "How to Cook with Halloweentown"
I mean the possibilities are endless aren't they?
The first one I couldn't really get into aside from the makeup and the second one
I thought was legitimately enjoyable even though they were bound to just a few locations the third one falls somewhere in between
It pretty much just jumps right in there as we see our favorite family is toying with the idea of maybe having kids from Halloweentown go to school
In the real world. In literally a flash, the eldest daughter
(Who is actually the only daughter now the youngest one seems to have just disappeared).. Yeah, Honestly no big loss
Is in front of the Halloween Town Council as willing to put her idea to the test except
well her magic is on the line as well as the magic of her entire family.
Oops.. So the kids from Halloween town are in disguise as Canadians. (Yeah for an exchange there,
that's really gonna be a culture shock.)
Who are dressed up as humans and are trying to be shown that monsters and humans can get along.
But unfortunately this evil organization known as the Knights.
Wants to keep these two groups separate because they still think humans are evil, not tolerant and are just gonna be awful for them.
And as we discover, they're willing to do anything to keep them apart.
I'm not gonna lie when I heard Halloweentown High the first thing that came in my head is "oh cool a school in Halloweentown!"
seeing a bunch of ghouls and monsters
learn all sorts of creative things. It's kind of a letdown knowing not only is it monsters going to the real world school.
But it's monsters that aren't even allowed to be monsters. They have to be in disguise looking like real kids.
That's not much fun.
Because of this we don't really get that much in terms of visuals and weird makeup and such.
Every once in a whilethere's something cool like
marshmallow spiders, a bag that walks and eats people.
And even the Halloween kids are allowed to take off their disguises once in a while
And is it me or did Dreamworks Trolls totally ripped us off?
Thankfully though the movie mostly makes up with this with some okay writing and some genuinely good performances.
I mean for a Disney Channel movie. I think we know we're not gonna get anything spectacular here.
It's funny seeing these actors who are just so uncomfortable and awkward in the first film suddenly seem very
natural and very interested in what they're saying as any good actor should be. Any weird strange stuff
they have to say they really try their hardest to make sound like this is just an everyday thing. And even the humans reacting to
Their odd ways get a few laughs. I especially love this boy's reaction when all the kids suddenly disappear into one car
[Cody]: Why does none of this surprise me?
[NC]: That seems so believable to me.
The message is made pretty clear as the villains once they're revealed
are trying to make a whole group of people look bad based on the actions of only a few.
And I'm not gonna lie while I'm recording this and watching the news, this message does hold a lot more relevance now than it probably did back then.
It's kind of like Zootopia what I thought was a little too obvious and in-your-face.
Sadly it turns out is very very needed nowadays.
So I guess even it's very simple message has a lot more relevance.
The only thing that was starting to get on my nerves a little bit the performance of the brother. I don't know.
He's seeming a little too one-note to me just always complaining always whining making fun of everything. Don't get me wrong
this is very hard dialogue to make sound
likable. And gets even stranger when he starts dating one of the kids from Halloweentown until he sees what she really looks like and
suddenly he's disgusted. It's given a little bit of a spin we discover. She thinks he's disgusting too.
It's kind of an interesting point of view for kids the gross monster sees us as gross monsters.
But in the end when it looks like they're gonna see past it
they still say that they find each other gross, and they just decided to be friends. What a confusing message.
So yeah where there are a lot of possibilities that should have been taken advantage of? Yes.
Are there a lot more creative elements that should have been here? Absolutely.
But for what it is it kept my interest I wanted to know what was gonna happen
I want to know how they're gonna get out of the predicament.
I enjoy the monsters point of view as well as the humans point of view and when they did have those creative elements they were
a lot of fun. I guess if you're curious to see it just to say you've seen all the Halloweentown movies
It's not bad to check out.
It's not gonna take anything to new levels or anything, but that's totally ok. Nothing while worthy, but passable enough.